[Music]
welcome to the second episode of between
two ponds today with us is our grand
master residents of the st. Louis chess
club Vladimir georgiev nice to meet you
thanks for coming soon mr. LAN so when
did you become Grandmaster efficiently I
got the title mm mm oh yeah after the
Congress right right right but I played
on the level of God master minions yeah
I go like I have 2565 maybe four five
years ago before officially I become
Gaea how long did you be playing chess
taller than before that tough questions
maybe like less than 20 years laughter
ow
less than two inches okay so do you feel
like your journey to being um a
grandmaster was normal was that typical
or they feel like that's what everyone
else was doing or what was your take on
your own personal journey to that that's
what I wanted to do all my life
even I was in doing it was City for
three years then I decided to stop to
focus more on chess and after that I
quickly become GM what were you studying
here but what would path you would you
have gone down and had nothing chess no
idea I always wanted to play chess and
woody what do you tribute that to you
like as a kid it was that introduced at
a young age or why do you think you
always had that passion for chess maybe
because my parents was playing chess at
home right I mean my mom and my father
and then I wanted to play chess - I
played in the kindergarten then why I
was 5 years old and then I wanted to
play a little chess and then Simon the
chess club I was going there at my pro
fast I become many times champion of
Bulgaria for all this age five fifth
grade sixth grade seventh grade eighth
away all this under-20 then for the men
and basically I wanted to play chess on
my way right that's awesome
so what's your most memorable game my
most memorable game is against Carson I
played against Kim 2014 and she was
number one and then the same years I
played against
Kurama who was number two and now again
that number one and two I mean I lost
both game but of course they're very
memorable and I was very surprised at my
play Carson and I was thinking people
joking to me I say no no don't joke with
me I couldn't play him in the clothes I
was playing second Norwegian legal team
competition we was playing final match
that team who quali
win will qualified for the top division
right and they told me the match is in
Oslo maybe who could come tomorrow
because he in signing the club but he
never played right but say okay of
course he will not come you know but
then they told me he decided to come he
wanted to see his friends to support
them and then I played him I was very
excited yes I celebrated after the
evening doesn't matter I lost I was
really right it's all things than that
yeah yeah at that point so who's the
highest rated player you be was a lamb
off the when I beat him he was number
six in the world so after he won't Hugh
Grant please he was like 27 60 and a
point I exactly the make it was number
six in the world where I beat him now
he's not so strong but I was close to
beat to power when he was number one in
the world but Institute right when I
made that Peto check so with when you
come as a noise and you play do you play
better here or were here was here what
do you think it is because I already was
coaching so how you know it's completely
different to be professional chess
player very focus on you are also right
than to think about preparing other and
then just to play because to kind of
keep in shape you ain't in shape yes
so that's why when I started to play
first time in centuries like 2014 or 15
I don't remember I was not so strong
like before it's your main is coaching
your main job is that what you're doing
yes
private lessons whatnot yeah you how do
you get your students how do you find
students the treats usually they find
the cool right so I'm not really not
listening to myself right so they heard
maybe I'm coaching some good students
and like that they contact me okay so
what's your favorite game besides chess
be forced to come here in USA I mean I'm
living since 2014 USA I like soccer
mainly but after I move here I like more
football American football yeah I enjoy
to which it's very strategic game for
myself I like to see what decision coach
is taking yeah yes they have this
specially when playing this game called
game yeah short of time and time outs
and it's very interesting for me to
watch if you were not playing chess
professionally you're not coaching
you're not teaching what do you think
you'd be doing you could do anything
else I never thought about his it's
tough maybe when I was kids I played
soccer maybe I could become good soccer
player there are lost but they might
consider to stop psychologists to focus
on right right what are your thoughts on
watching Bishop right now of difficult
questions
everybody expect I mean hope not really
expect hope for some decisive game to
become more interesting but the treats
everybody likes to become world champion
nobody like to us games so if they are
doing their best but the pressure is
very high a little bit more high not
little bit maybe more high in Colorado
because his first try to become a
champion if he not gonna win maybe he'll
never get the same chance so that's why
it's not easy for him either and I think
he understand he should try to push more
to win maybe in the regular time because
in the tiebreak I think Carson has more
chances and that's why I expected now to
be more risk from Caruana and probably
some decisive game also I can see
they're becoming tired
that it's easy to understand because
they even not from the real game they
becoming time from the whole process
preparation and then right before the
match and then during them much
surprises yeah so mentally is very tough
what would you do differently if
anything as an organizer to make either
the gameís more decisive or more you
know that the viewing public definitely
is is upset that the games of all the
drawers but you know what they're for
the following you think there's
something the organizers could do
differently what I like I might told
many years ago because they were
sodomized amid tournament in Sofia until
master with popplets
I for me the most logic it's two games
per day fifteen minutes or even one hour
without delay without increment let's
say fifty minutes plus ten minutes ten
seconds right delay but no increment I
hate increment because that's not logic
to me in any sport they are not gonna
give you extra time because you need
time to score or whatever and that's why
in football you have timing ya clock is
going fast and you should be dance
attack yeah faster for example I think
to game she's good per day one hour per
game white and black everybody's keeping
more rounds that I think it's very fair
no fight black or for black or for white
five black that's what I think is very
good alright well thank you for joining
us is great thank you for inviting me do
you guys have any questions at home
we'll probably give it to them again
welcome to our comment commentary
section of between two ponds where I
respond to readers questions on our last
week's video between two ponds and the
first thing I want to address is why
we're not uploading any of the World
Chess Championship live today in chess
coverage and we will be doing that but
do the nature of the World Chess
Championship
we're not posting any of our today in
chess shows or interviews for
rebroadcast until the conclusion of the
match so once it's over they'll all go
up but you can watch live every time
there's around at 9 a.m. Central so to
get to the reader responses first lasso
lucid hora wants to know who are the
pawns and what is between them excellent
question
Artem ms5 msk says a great episode
much love to Jesse
the way he teaches chess in his videos
and I wish the interview with the chess
philosopher it would be longer throbber
wants us to know that it's so boring now
that Feingold is gone
and lastly piggy pig-pig this is
overproduced garbage like someone had
just learned how to edit videos the
music and pawns to tract from the
interview
well piggy pig-pig this is why
[Music]
[Applause]
our next grandmaster in residence is
Caterina nem Sylva she will be here
after Thanksgiving for a long time so if
you have any questions for her please
email us and let us know Thanks
[Music]